the other side of the ideology is just
really weird and creepy okay and we just
got a video of this of chased him jason
is
pete buddha judge's partner
and he is
a pretty outspoken obviously uh on some
of these social issues if you're uh
associated with mr buddage who
tries to make every single thing he's
doing every time he passes some mundane
regulation at the transportation
department he tries to make it seems
like like he's the most radical social
reformer in america and set himself up
for president well buddha judge's
partner jason
a clip just came out of him
running a gay camp
with bizarre
cultish overtones
all right i pledge my heart
to the rainbow to the rainbow of the
not-so-typical gay camp
one camp
full of pride
indivisible indivisible with affirmation
and equal rights for all
rights for all watch your heads
and then he waves the rainbow flag this
stunt that he pulled
is extremely unpatriotic and extremely
sacrilegious
and i still find this guy more likeable
than pete buda judge somehow
because pete is just that unlikable but
what he did here is really it's really
unpatriotic you're you're asking
people to pledge their not just their
allegiance pledge their hearts
to the gay flag
he rewrites the pledge of allegiance to
the american flag and takes out the
american flag and takes out god
and replaces under god with full of
pride not only the a deadly sin but the
deadliest of the seven deadly sins it's
commonly been called the queen of vice
now some people say it is the vice of
queens i don't know i don't know i've
just heard that it's quite an inversion
but he he says
you you must pledge your heart
full of pride to the rainbow flag this
is a lot more than just a boy who likes
another boy
okay this is a lot more than just a
sexual desire and even this is a lot
more than even pursuing a sexual desire
that might be unusual
this is a radical ideology
this is i've said it for a long time at
the lgbt
elementary and it goes on and on
they're selling this to you
as though it were just a way to be nice
to people with sort of unusual sexual
desires
sex is almost secondary to the thing
it is a full-on
political cultural religious world view
that replaces america with your own
base desires and replaces god with pride
i mean it celebrates pride that's a
weird thing why don't why isn't it
you know celebrating
love why isn't it celebrating
individuality why pride why there's
there's always these sort of strange
religious overtones to it do you know
who unearthed the clip it wasn't some
homophobic
right-wing
anti-gay it was the log cabin
republicans
it was the gay republican group
unearthed that clip because there were a
lot of guys a lot of guys who are
attracted to other guys who looked at
that and said whoa man whatever that is
i'm out
count me out of that please i don't want
to be
a part of that
the cultural battle that we are seeing
right now especially in these laws in
the schools in florida the the
rule in georgia and idaho this in
virginia for that matter with the
governor's race with glenn younkin
the two sides are
hey maybe don't trans the kids
and
chasing and pete buddha judge versus
chasing it right those are the two polls
it's hey let's not tell my
five-year-olds
that maybe he's actually a little girl
versus
pledge your heart full of pride to the
rainbow flag huzzah huzzah
what do you think is going to win what
do you think is more popular what do you
think is
a more normal stable
attractive view of the individual end of
society i think
it's probably going to be
the don't trans the kids side of things
right now go to ring.com
knowles you know about the ring video
doorbell i've told you about it for
years did you know that ring makes an
alarm that's right a full-on
award-winning home security system it's
available with professional monitoring
when you subscribe best of all you can
install it yourself even i i'm not the
handiest guy in the world i need to hire
a team of contractors to screw in a
light bulb even i can install
ring i i know you've heard me talk about
that ring alarm well now i have got the
pro
the pro the ring alarm pro is where it
is at is it a it is a next level
security system cnet calls ring alarm
pro a giant leap for home security and
after using it i think they're
absolutely right ring alarm pro helps
protect the entire home and the wi-fi
that it runs on with ring alarm pro ring
combined a home security system with a
wi-fi router so this thing helps protect
your home and your network your physical
world and your digital world it's an
amazing product right now head on over
to
com
ring.com
knowles gopro be like me get that pro
kit right now ring.com slash knowles
canon wles no more amateur hour gopro
ring.com
knowles
i'm so glad you like that clip now
please please ring that bell subscribe
get the notifications and more
importantly even than that head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher
wherever you get your podcasts subscribe
to the michael knowles show
leave a five-star review if you wouldn't
mind really appreciate it we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]